let's say you want to solve a mass
problem that involves calculating a sum
of numbers using Chain of Thought
prompting you could break down the
problem into smaller more manageable
steps for instance you have five appos
and your friend give you two how many
apples do you have now so your coot
prompt should look like this start with
the number of apples you have five
apples and add the number of apples your
friend give you 5 + 2 and then then
count the total number of apples you
have which is seven this prompt guides
the language model to solve the problem
step by step making the reasoning
process more explicit and transparent
coot can be applied to a wide range of
task by breaking down the complex test
into smaller steps C help language model
to reason more effectively and Achieve
better performance